once every few decades someone comes out
of the blue to make a change that lasts
forever regarding race and changing
people's minds it's been three years
since George floor died and now we
finally have black G here
so we're out here trying to find out can
black people be racist talk about racism
yeah we can man and what's the solution
let's go can black people be racist yeah
we racist as [__]
that's how we started yeah yes we can
it's our own race but everybody got
their own racism with them within them
it ain't about color it could be uh
characteristic you don't like ghetto
people you don't like broke people you
mad at this it ain't about the color see
that's what people get to twist today
because I'm racism over trifling ass
people
how do we fix racism do we talk about it
more or less we'll talk about it more
you think so you think more yeah you
think we already talk about it a lot and
it seems like it keeps getting worse
right dude
your face is the most racism would you
say
you think black people people yeah black
people and black men the race of men the
the gender is men they have way more
strikes against their back who's more
racist black or white people I don't
know white people it's been known I'd
say that I think white people are can
black people be racist of course always
go crazy on me at school some black
friends yeah they go crazy what do they
call you just make fun of my race and
[__] W racism do you think black people
are racist yes and why is that because
we are
they just like I don't know oh [__]
we've been through we can't be racist
why can't black people be racist just
cause all the [__] we've been through
what is racism yeah it's one's a race
why would that mean that you can't be
racist I just feel like we've been
through too much we don't care so you
should set some [__] up [__] right
like to another race another thing I
don't that don't mean you racist what
does it mean racist they say honky Jew
all that so you know so when somebody
say [__] we get mad but yeah everybody
man who can say the n-word
there's a lot of black people like what
about Latinos no Mexicans games
they went to the same stuff we did
Mexicans can definitely say [__] and
white people say the n-word when they're
when it's in a song no why not you
better bleep it out
they said it for 400 years I don't need
to say it no more what's the solution to
racism talking about it more or less
can you explain ain't no reason to y'all
gonna be racist either way white people
that race is the most racist people out
here in the world is white people
are you racist I'm not racist they're
good I like the n-word uh you like you
might give them a pass
can a black person give someone else the
pass no I
don't know what's the solution to racism
then like what's what do we do
every business
our black business that's what it is
white people are yes white people are
always in our business and I probably
gotta go under their skin because we're
talking loud and telling the truth
because she's over there looking crazy
around let's get ready let's get busy
baby racism right there is that the
color of your skin or because you're
screaming
people out what if they just don't like
loud people
how is that racism no no that's y'all
prayers are not like
racist and they didn't really do
anything wrong like don't you think
that's because I said it might be caring
an example of racism right now can black
people be racist yeah everybody could be
racist why do you think some black
people think that they can't be racist
nowadays because there is because
they're racist what's the solution to
racism we talk about it more or less my
love bro Bob Marley talk about less man
and just love each other bro can black
people be racist I'm racist yeah again
too white people I don't like I don't
like y'all as a white person you could
never say that about black people why do
you think that is because yeah
can you be racist to white people and
now but y'all can't be racist to us
either y'all
you can't be racist to white people no
it's not fair like she just said like I
don't like white people like isn't that
like
oh
no we used to be our slaves so like why
would I like y'all now boom
how did we get to this oh political
figures used to be So based destroying
victim mentality Obama 10 years ago
saying how sometimes I wrote off my own
failings as just as another example of
the world trying to keep a black man
down I had a tendency sometimes to make
excuses for me not doing the right thing
but one of the things that all of you
have learned over the last four years is
there's no longer any room for excuses
based killing the idea that bad things
happening to you surprise bad things
happen to everyone are due to the color
of your skin to now are reparations
justify the answer is yes pushing
victimhood if the idea plagues your mind
bad things are happening because you're
black now every time someone doesn't
hold the door for you gives you a weird
look and it was only Caucasian woman in
there and everybody was looking at me a
cop pulls you over now it's because
you're black not because sometimes
people are just [__] next time you
get pulled over ask the officer his name
shake his hand be polite don't just
start screaming at him if someone's
giving you weird looks give them a
friendly smile back this [__] goes a
long way no she's making the wrong Point
what do you think you treat people how
you want to be treated if white people
won't respect from black people they
need to give black people the same
respect I agree yes that's the moral of
the situation if you like me I'ma like
you I love you me I ain't gonna like you
but if we could be together forever
like white guys
maybe she just said I don't like white
people and it's acceptable to say that
well most of the people are fighting
racism with racism so it's like just
helping the cause as you said yeah so
it's like hypocrite you got any
questions what is your type my type is
uh Arab Arab woman
yeah exactly are you Muslim yeah I'm
Muslim
I think I've seen you on on YouTube like
you do video with your mom right yeah
yeah okay I've seen you yeah I watch a
lot of your videos oh you've watched
this song once you understand the
religion very well like you know like
blaspheme and it's very fun to see you
oh thank you I really appreciate that I
really respect that I respect that yeah
I totally like I understand why people
would want to see it because like for
the longest time I have that biased view
of Muslims like you grow up like you see
like 9 11 and like the way they're
portrayed in the media and then you
start looking in the religion and you're
like oh Jesus is in this oh we both kind
of believe in the same God like it's
it's weird once you realize how similar
our religions really are it's crazy how
how Divided We Are by the media I think
it is good for people to see that kind
of truly I really respect because like I
see you like opening your mind to it and
at once I was I was Christian before I'm
really Latino I'm from Peru and then I
reverted back to to being a Muslim so
yeah like last year so yeah I really
respect your your videos about Islam and
everything yeah bro it honestly pisses
me off because like I'm not trying to
come out here with an agenda and make
like my stepbrother is black like I
don't even like really I don't know how
many people know that when the girl says
she goes I don't [__] with white people
it's like for all like that's not how we
[__] solved it her friends corrected
her too she that's good at least she
knew she knew she [__] up but it's
okay though you know we changing the
world uniting people together black G
and sunny yes look look at this look at
this chat you know what it is like I
feel like racism isn't necessarily a bad
thing so black people white people Asian
people that's what I'm saying so like
especially if someone gets me tight bro
oh my God bro I'm flaming you no but my
Point's like if I'm walking my dog I've
noticed that black people don't like to
pet dogs when I'm walking is that right
should I pull my dog away I don't [__]
with big dogs
no bro that [__] is ass I put my dog
away from black people oh right because
you guys don't like them I don't want my
dog to get kicked can black people be
racist yes
can you be racist to white people yes
a lot of the black people that I've
interviewed tonight have said that you
uh can't why do you think that is
because they're ignorant right people
can be racist just like white people
it's your birthday
it's all about birthdays
what are your thoughts on black people
going out wearing durags and stuff like
that be honest I do not like it it's
ghetto
yeah it's ghetto it's not a way for you
to represent yourself you shouldn't be
in do rags you shouldn't be yes you do
you shouldn't be in durags you shouldn't
be in bonnets you shouldn't be in
pajamas you shouldn't be in wife beaters
that's on sagging like it walking around
with your ass and your underwear showing
is not okay in fact it comes from prison
to me sagging means that you want
somebody to take that ass
and then it evolved into which role a
prisoner would have during male on male
Prison Sex what do you think of the
solutions for the black community
because a lot of that stuff is really
prevalent with the with the youth for
everybody to come together on the same
side we as blacks we need to come
together more yeah and we need to do
better I'm looking at different races as
if they're the enemies racism to me is
Todd
racism racism is taught in a home and
it's usually coming from ancestors
people that um older Generations as
bringing these Generations up with that
same mentality and it's not right my
kids are taught not to see color you see
people well here they are and you don't
look at a color hey buddy make sure yeah
you you get raised like this please can
black people be racist oh yes but people
could be racist black people can be
racist but I feel like it's Justified
why why do I feel like it's Justified
okay only when it's dealing with
Caucasians no offense I'm so sorry to
you baby I feel like it's Justified
because as an African-American black
woman I feel like I have to be on um
Edge or be prepared for a white person
to be racist to me so who why do you
think that is is that from personal
experience or from the media okay I'm
gonna say based on personal experience
and the media it's 2023 we have to be
real people how often do you really face
racism out in the street how often do I
face it like white people coming up to
you and just like okay to be honest has
it ever happened it's never happened
based on personal experience so wouldn't
you say that's a hundred percent the
media then because you're saying you
feel like you have to defend yourself
from white people honest okay I got my
nails done on um Wednesday and it was a
Vietnamese and it was only Caucasian
women in there and everybody was looking
at me so I felt the eyes of my body so
um yeah I feel like they didn't know he
was valid huh
well no my house like damn sugar oh they
said damn sugar that's what they were
thinking oh
what's the solution so you've never even
faced racism from a white person but
you're already out here kind of bashing
them in a way I'm not I'm
not you've never even faced it so like
if you heard of them if you watch The
Matrix no I've never seen The Matrix but
I've seen Harry Potter so like you
recognize that there's people that
control the media and agendas right
absolutely they want to control what you
think but I don't follow shade room or
Hollywood unlocked I don't follow them
okay so would you think that there would
be people that would want to keep us
divided by telling a group of people
that you need to be hostile of the other
ones at all times I don't think that um
is people trying to control social media
I think people are just recording what's
happening in the real world and they're
not hiding it from us can black people
be racist I mean everybody's racist and
you be racist to white people no I love
white people oh you're like the first
okay I love like black men or white men
I like black men
oh
my God no yeah I'm asking because a lot
of the people out here they think that
you physically can't be racist to white
people like racism doesn't apply to
white people why do you think people
think that I don't know they're simple
mind I mean anybody could be racist to
anybody can black people be racist yes
no I don't feel like we should be braces
you can say you go you can say hello to
a white person it's like they don't even
say thank you that's just rude people
that happens to everyone still if they
could be racist we should be racist how
do you think you solve racism by keep
continuously being racist or being but
even when I gotta change it so even when
we not being racist there's still people
being racist to us so make it right
though two wrongs don't make it right so
what's the solution what do you think
talk we talk about it more or less
racism talk about it more but we don't
how often do you guys face racism in the
real world like people come up to you
and call you the n-word or stuff like
that happen we don't face it but in our
city like you could see it though like
you could but
see the difference between like white
like white police and black men like you
could really see the big difference
a lot of police killing young black men
and even the oldest for nothing for
nothing
for no reason
for instance a 17 year old boy in our
city just got shot in the back running
from the police and they try to say he
was a threat to their life and they shot
him four times in his back that's for
nothing
the other boy in Baltimore that was in
his call they taste his car down and hit
and hit this cone he died just like
Darnell y'all know the fact you're doing
right thank you
he was gay darn that long lived on now
all right so I did some research into
rainbow Darnell to check out their story
and this guy was wanted on a warrant for
failing to appear in court on a car
tracking charge the police tried to stop
him when running plates and he got shot
when trying to run over one of the
police officers with his car actually
here indeed multiple shots being fired
into the car and the car started moving
before one officer Falls it honestly
makes me sad to talk about this stuff
because the media uses so many instances
just like this to push their agenda of
systemic racism and instilling
victimhood fear into black people if you
dive into basically any of the BLM cases
it's the same story news title oh no I'm
the black man shot by white police
officer then the Macy's gets looted
breaking into Macy's Flagship Herald
Square store and stealing about ten
thousand dollars worth of merchandise
and then the body cam footage gets
released and you see the guy was trying
to stab a cop or had double the lethal
dose of fentanyl in the system my goal
with sharing this isn't to be some Ben
Shapiro puppet but I want you guys to
realize we're really on the same team to
question why you have the beliefs that
you do and who instilled them
is this a problem so you're talking
about police brutality just for black
people or do white people face it too oh
they don't they don't whoa whoa do you
think that white people just don't face
it or the media just doesn't cover it
don't cover it that's they cover you'll
see a police telling a white man like
Put the gun down Put the gun down relay
hand walk it was a black [__] he would
have been shot him so the solution is we
talk about it more yes can black people
be racist yeah can you be racist to
white people
oh no no why not because it's like how
I'm gonna be racist to a white person
but I could be racist to like mix people
like Hispanic people what is racism
racism I don't know like the actual
definition but like how can you be
racist to mix people but you can't be
racist to white people what an oppressed
y'all not how are you oppressed because
we was oppressed with slavery criticism
all types of stuff are you still
oppressed today yes cause like there's
people who give you looks people who say
stuff people giving you looks is
oppression no but it's literally trying
to like understand like how like how
often do you literally face racism from
white people like in your day to day not
really it's like rare you think we blow
up this racism talk a lot more than it
really is in the real world yeah I do
what do you think the solution is talk
about it less
more but less because like if you talk
about it more people understand it more
and they'll stop talking about it
because it's like really not their real
so you you you haven't had really have
you ever had a like a white person just
call it the n-word on the street or like
so that's never happened to you no so
why do a lot of the black people that
I've interviewed tonight have had that
same answer but why do you guys still
feel hostile or like white people are
hostile towards you I don't why do you
think that is do you think it's the
media yeah do you think the media is
getting under people's skins to divide
them yeah so we should start questioning
the media more yeah I hope you do that
in the future help like change the way
you look at stuff at all like that I
don't just call people racist today we
solved racism with black G that's some
black queens tell them like And
subscribe like And subscribe hit the
Bell
join the newsletter join the newsletter
peace guys
[Music]